the vision of NMOS data analysis
simplified to make your life easier and
I'm going to show you just how simple it
can be
so to start I've got a couple of example
files here they're both housing price
indexes one is for Colorado the other
ones for Texas I'm gonna take Texas for
now click and drag it in here and upload
alternatively you can use the file
picker there once you upload the first
thing that comes up is a visualization
of your dataset if it's a time series
underneath that you've got an
interactive table of your data you can
either browse through the data here or
you can search entries here next you can
scroll up to the analysis tab and if
you're feeling lucky you can generate a
forecast of your data or maybe you're
looking for something a little more
similar like a transformation such as a
moving average now for all
transformations you make you can either
look at them you could choose to swipe
them away by clicking on that button or
below them you can do things like
download the image of it download the
CSV that comprises it or you can choose
to merge it with the data set look like
that what you get in return is immerged
value of the data set don't worry your
original data still remains you can come
over to the dashboard and both files are
here you can choose what you want to do
with it if you want to keep the old data
there go ahead otherwise go ahead and
delete it don't pull back up the merge
data file and at this point we can see
that the title and the line names are
really not ideal so what we're going to
do is we're going to come over to the
manipulate tab choose renaming and we're
going to rename this data set we're
going to call the data set HPI the value
is actually a texas HPI and this is a
texas HPI 55 moving average we'll go
ahead hit submit and now what comes up
is the new data set with the proper
names happy with it download the image
or the CSV now because we added a 55
moving average some of that initial data
is missing it's a 55 moving average so
the first 54 points just can't be
calculated so one thing you can do is
you can come over to the manipulate tab
come down to cleaning missing data and
you can choose to handle missing data in
a variety of ways you can drop any rows
that contain any column with missing
data you can do a forward fill which
takes previous data and fills it forward
you can do a back fill which takes
preceding data and fills it backwards or
you can choose to replace it with a
value such as maybe zero in
case I'm gonna choose none of these and
actually we're going to remove that
entire line and we're gonna come up to
remove columns we're gonna remove the
Texas HP i-55 moving average submit and
now that line is gone so I'm gonna head
back to the dashboard I'm gonna clear
out those two extra files so that would
be this one and this one so I'm gonna
read back actually we'll leave this one
here and we're gonna bring in the other
datasets so this would be the Texas HPI
and now we're going to go ahead and
bring in that Colorado HPI so I'm gonna
click and drag that one in hit upload
bring it back up and again we've got a
relatively generic name for this line
which is value so I'm gonna go ahead and
come over to manipulate rename and
instead of value that would be CEO HP I
go ahead and hit submit there and now
we're happy with this line now what we
have is two data sets within this
account that have relatively identical
data at least along their index which is
a date/time index so one thing that we
can do is we can come to the manipulate
tab we can combine data sets and here we
can choose to combine this data set with
another data set now you can do one of
two things you can either use a document
ID and you can fill in any document ID
that is to a data set that's Publix that
you have access to if you're not
familiar with the data ID you can either
find it here in your account or if
you're able to view it it's in the URL
once you have that actually I'm going to
use the drop-down because we have it and
we're looking to merge it with the
original just HPI dot CSV because that
was the Texas one now what we're looking
to do is actually add columns so I'm
gonna go ahead and click on that and hit
submit and now you have emerged data set
so one thing we can do is we can cover
to the stats and see some basic
statistics here like how many entries do
we have what's the average number for
each of them standard deviation and then
below that we've got a dataset
correlation table which just compares
the columns and calculates the
correlation as you can see these are
highly correlated with each other but
maybe you want to see a little bit more
into the correlation maybe over time so
we can come over to the analysis compare
and we can compare the Colorado HPI to
the Texas HPI
and we could do something like a rolling
correlation compare and sure enough
there you go now maybe you're just
looking but as
you can always merge with the data set
and now what you have is the merged data
you've got that rolling correlation and
you've also got the original data here
again if you want download the image or
download the CSV if you download the
image you actually get both images and
the CSV just contains all of the data so
while a lot of operations on enzmann are
focused on time series data we can also
handle non time series data as well for
example we use the quite popular iris
dataset which is included on the sample
data in the home page we'll go ahead and
click on this this data set is often
used with machine learning for
classification because it just simply
lends itself very nicely to doing that
so what we have here are columns which
are sepal width sepal length petal
length petal width and then the class
the iris is a flower these are
measurements of certain attributes of
that flower and then we have the class
in this case there are three classes
iris setosa virginica and vera color now
cooperation with data sets like these is
to take the data set but actually select
data from the data set where something
is the case so for example you might
want to select all the rows in this data
set where the class is equal to say iris
setosa so the way we can do that is
coming up to the manipulate tab we can
filter by column content and then we're
going to choose specific value range and
we're gonna choose class and then iris
setosa we'll go ahead and hit submit and
sure enough what we get in return is
just 50 entries the original dataset was
150 and these are all with iris setosa
where the class's iris setosa now what
if actually what you wanted to do was
split up the file into every unique
class in this case you could do what we
just did three times but what if you had
maybe a hundred classes or something
like that that would be pretty pretty
tedious so instead what we can do is
we'll come back to the homepage click on
IRS data go to manipulate and this time
we're gonna filter by column content
instead we're gonna choose by unique
values and then we're gonna go ahead and
choose class submit this is just asking
because basically what's gonna happen is
we're gonna create new files this will
only create three but if you say we're
using stock data and you try to create
new files based on the price tab
you might end up with millions of files
so we're gonna go ahead and hit yes here
and what happens is we get three new
datasets and sure enough we get them
split up by their value iris virginica
very color and Tosa now what if you
wanted to combine them back well we've
already covered combining things so we
can open up virginica manipulate
combining and then instead we're gonna
choose setosa we're adding rows we'll go
ahead and do that and then again we'll
do one more combining datasets and we're
gonna add very color at rows and now we
have the combined data set I'll buy it
with a very very long title we'll go
ahead and go to manipulate renaming and
this will just be iris data submit as
you can see just because you didn't fill
the other values if you don't feel
anything in the original title is
retained so now let's do what this
dataset was meant for and that is
predict things so in the case of this
dataset we've got three major classes
along with measurements the idea is you
could find a new iris not knowing the
class measure these four attributes and
then come to your machine learning
classifier and say hey I've got these
four attributes let's say six three six
and three please predict what class of
iris this is and hopefully the return
would be iris virginica now in business
one might uses to classify a type of
customer maybe even the customers
interest and we would use attributes
from previous known customers and their
interests and then compare new customer
attributes to try to predict what type
of customer that new person is so
companies use this to predict what type
of music you would like what kind of
movies you might like or books and so on
so let's test this against the iris data
in this case we'll use something pretty
simple we can see that an at least
pretty close value for an iris virginica
would be six three six and three that is
not a value that's ever been seen in
this data set you can go ahead and
scroll through if you'd like but none of
these for iris virginica are 6-3 6-3 so
what we're going to go ahead and do is
come over to the analysis tab choose
predict
and the column that we're looking to
predict is class and then we're just
gonna fill these in so 6-3 6-3 and then
we'll hit predict sure enough the
prediction is IRAs virginica confidence
high 90 5.56% you can click here to
learn more about the confidence and how
predictions are done now at least on
this data set we probably could have
done that just by eyeballing it
ourselves but imagine if you had
customer data with a hundred thousand
rows or a million rows that would be
very very challenging so there you have
it ends Moe data analysis simplified